the national advisory committee on
immunization nasi is now recommending
those who are over the age of 80 or
long-term care residents get prioritized
for their second booster doses six
months after their first
the advisory body adds it could soon
expand the recommendation to include
canadians over 70. in the u.s second
boosters are already approved for those
50 plus experts say for the average
person three doses provides sufficient
protection it will add a little bit to
your protection but essentially the the
idea of abandoning all other things and
rushing out there and getting your
fourth shot that's not so important
right now let's leave the fourth shot to
those people who really need it federal
officials say they are reviewing
recommendations for adults under 50 with
guidance to be released in the coming
weeks immunocompromised canadians are
already recommended to get their fourth
shots
47 of canadians have received a third
dose which many epidemiologists now
believe should be considered fully
vaccinated jamie morocco global news
toronto